when you sit there and think about signs
you know like if i look at the
in my business and i'll say i have seven
cancers
they're earners okay different
background
one has a degree one doesn't have a
degree parents religion
you know upbringing dad was there that
wasn't there
you know major setback in teens major
setback
in 20s you know uh then a bad
relationship a bad
you know betrayal you know all of that
religious beliefs all of that stuff kind
of makes up who we are
but the foundation would you say the
foundation is still
our sign based on where you believe as
somebody that's been doing this for 50
years what would you say would be the
foundation of
my dna my individual as who i am patrick
that david
well i'll give you i'll give you a
little bit of an insight to
the way i i talk to a person they ask
they're
coming to me with the same question
whether they actually ask it or not
i say look at the moment that um your
body
takes a first breath you got to
understand you're not your body
your body is something a mother made and
while it's in the womb
it's a water-breathing creature even has
gills
breathes drinks works with amniotic
fluid
mother puts it out into the room can't
breathe
got a traumatic experience already gets
whacked on the bottom
goes like that well what comes in with
the breath
almost like a trojan horse that air
carries your spiritual dna
and that is the conf
the the way the solar system is at the
moment
and it comes into you uh into your body
that way
and the reason that that that is the
case for everybody
is because you know the moon goes around
the earth
and you have this uh was borrowed from
quantum physics
whole idea of the wave state of the moon
is its orbit
it makes uh the earth a yoke it becomes
the womb of the solar system
and so everything that is going on in
the solar system is solar system
manifesting creating all kinds of
versions of itself
and that's because if you look at what
the uh
cosmologists have been saying for the
last 20
30 years the cosmos seems to be
attempting to become
aware of itself and that means
that it seems to be to fine-tuned to
create life
so it has a sense of being alive
so if if the cosmos is alive in that way
the solar system is alive in that way
because it's a part of it
so the solar system is comprised of the
sun
and the sun is 99.86 percent of the mass
of the solar system
so that means a very very small amount
for all the rest of it
so the sun is the creator if you will or
the animator
and the planets are like the genes
they're like the
organs of the solar system so the solar
system is you
at the time you were born the solar
system becomes you
and me when me but it's the same solar
system
produced the same sun in the sky when
you were born i was born
so when people start talking about this
woo-woo stuff we're all one
there is a cosmological reality to that
so the foundation is
when you take your first breath that
path you're on whatever is rising so
you've been on this
path of leo rising you've been
challenging
yourself from the day you were born and
in your experiences coming out
of iran and in the whole idea of being
a refugee and so forth what you saw
in those years from 7 to 12
13 and 14. man you know
you were not really satisfied with
that's
good you were upset and you
took that upset and decided i'm getting
out of there
and i'm going to find a way out of there
and around 10 or 12
the whole circumstance arrived total
confusion on your part as to what was
happening
all of a sudden you found yourself in
the united states
and you looked at the united states and
you heard what they were saying and said
you can be anybody you want here
you said that's for me i i know what i
want to be
because i know what i have been and i
have been lost in
poor and angry no more nobody's going to
push me around
ever again and on top of that i've got
something to offer
and i want to work to serve and help
people that's my whole deal
i'm here to help people and the only way
i can do that according to your chart
is to learn and learn and learn i can't
at the time when you started thinking
this way i can't afford to go to
university anymore
well okay i'll bring them to me i'll
bring these teachers to me rather than
me having to pay bucks
all kinds of money to just go hear what
i think i already know
so that's a short version of
how your your path is going now you know
i'm october 18th i'm a libra i was born
october 18th
october 18 1978
the sun is in the last 10 degrees of
libra and what follows that is one two
three four planets in scorpio
the investigator the guy is going to get
into and find out what makes it all
tick i want to know why this works
let's understand it not only that
but i hope that it changes
my financial situation what i learned
or it can change my values it can can
even i i
i even want to believe in something
believe it or not i want to believe and
so please give me something to believe
in
and the end result was i believe in me
that's the driver but to me
that you are is an aspect of this thing
called the cosmos which is you must call
god
if you want to call it something you
know there's all kinds of concepts of
god
among um people of the world you you can
go from islam
to buddhism you can go from buddhism to
you name it right well what you have is
nobody really know
um but you end up having to feel it
and in your case you know the whole
business
of how you you were able to transcend
things was because of
the way that you felt about your family
background and upbringing and everything
you were hit 24
5 6 and you were unhappy
clearly about how your mom and dad were
doing whatever they were doing and
all the experiences and you're upset so
you said
okay i'm going to get out of this and
i'm going to develop myself
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye